Salut la team mentalos! Souvent, sur cette chaîne, on parle d'imaginaire, de visualisation, de mémoire avec des images, ...
Mais bien souvent, dans les commentaires, vous me dites que c'est un petit peu compliqué pour vous de faire travailler votre imagination.
C'est pourquoi, aujourd'hui, je vous fait un master class' sur la visualisation et l'imagerie mentale.
Le but, c'est que vous arriviez à visualiser des choses correctement en 3D dans votre esprit, voire même les yeux ouverts.
Les techniques sur lesquelles je me suis appuyé pour me former au départ viennent des recommandations que faisait Nicolas Tesla à ce sujet.
Nicolas Tesla, ça vous parle : c'est un grand inventeur. Il est né en 1856 en Croatie. Il a déposé plus de 1000 brevets.
Il parlait 12 langues. Il avait une mémoire photographique et une capacité de visualisation exceptionnelle.
Il a conçu la plupart de ses inventions de tête.
Dans ce master class', je vais vous donner 4 exercices et un vrai conseil à la toute fin.
Ces 4 exercices ne sont pas des tests. Le but, ce n'est pas d'essayer de le faire et de passer au suivant.
Il s'agit plus d'une méthodologie que je vous propose.
Faites le premier exercice. Le jour où vous le maîtrisez tranquillement, à 100%,
alors, vous pourrez passer au 2ième exercice.
Idem pour ce 2ième exercice, et ensuite, vous passerez au 3ième.
Suivez bien toute la vidéo puisque je donne un vrai conseil très important à la fin et j'ai une petite annonce à vous faire pour une vidéo de la semaine prochaine.
Pour muscler votre visualisation, le premier exercice, c'est que vous allez prendre une photo,
essayer de l'imprimer, tant qu'à faire pour l'avoir toujours sur vous.
Ca vous permettra de vous entraîner n'importe où.
Vous allez regarder la photo et la détailler au maximum.
Ca prendra le temps que ça prendra, mais détaillez la photo au maximum.
Tous les détails, tout : la luminosité, les couleurs, les formes, l'organisation, tout, complètement.
Ensuite, je suis sûr que vous l'avez deviné, vous cachez la photo et vous devez la revisualiser de tête, mentalement.
Essayez de vous rappeler un maximum de détails, mais pas en sub-vocalisant, pas en vous parlant dans votre tête,
mais vraiment en essayant de voir l'image devant vous.
Au départ, ça risque d'être un petit peu compliqué, mais ça va venir rapidement.
Travaillez sur la même photo, jusqu'à temps que vous arriviez à le faire complètement.
A chaque fois que vous essayez de l'imaginer, une fois que vous avez fait ce travail-là, vous reprenez la photo,
vous essayez de voir les détails que vous aviez oubliés, ou pas, et vous refaites l'exercice jusqu'à tant que vous le maîtrisiez.
Evidemment, vous pouvez aussi changer de photo si vous voulez pour en prendre une plus simple ou une plus compliquée pour vous tester.
Une fois que vous aurez maîtriser tout ça, ça va commencer à venir, on va passer à un côté plus amusant :
vous allez prendre un objet. Je vous recommande un objet relativement simple.
Un stylo, un paquet de cartes, un dé, un briquet, un téléphone portable, ...
Et vous allez faire le même travail qu'avec la photo.
Vous allez le tenir dans vos mains, vous allez le regarder, vous allez prendre en compte la sensation que vous avez.
Si c'est du métal, vous allez ressentir le froid, par exemple, et la dureté.
Vous devez donc le modéliser dans votre tête, mais en 3D.
Vous devez être capable de le tourner dans votre tête, de le mettre dans plein de positions différentes,
en étant capable, à chaque fois, de l'imaginer dans ses moindres détails.
Si vous avez fait les exercices dans l'ordre, vous ne devriez pas avoir trop de difficultés, en tout cas, pas  plus qu'avec le premier.
Après, pour vous tester, vous allez fermer les yeux. Vous allez essayer de l'imaginer comme ça devant vous,
de le bouger un petit peu, de le regarder par au-dessus, par en-dessous, devant, derrière, ...
Et là, vous allez pouvoir muscler encore plus votre visualisation en faisant deux choses :
la première, ça va être d'essayer de le faire les yeux ouverts. Vous allez y arriver. A terme, vous allez y arriver, c'est sûr!
Vous allez projeter l'image devant vous, un petit peu comme dans la réalité augmentée.
A l'instar d'un hologramme qui serait devant vous, vous allez le visualiser en le superposant à la réalité.
Puis, toujours les yeux ouverts, ou en fermant les yeux, vous allez imaginer cet objet dans un environnement,
Tout en faisant agir l'environnement avec l'objet.
Si l'objet que je visualise, par exemple, c'est un téléphone, je peux l'imaginer très près de moi ou posé au loin sur une table,
mais avec les soleil qui tape dessus, donc, il faut que j'imagine forcément le reflet.
Ce qui est passionnant, c'est que votre cerveau sait déjà tout, comment les choses réagissent.
Si vous imaginez le soleil qui tape comme ça, vous allez avoir le bon reflet dans votre tête.
Votre cerveau le sait!
Pour passer enfin au 3ième exercice qui est plus agréable :
Vous allez vous imaginer vous, à la 1ère personne, au travers de vos yeux à vous,
vous ne vous voyez pas en extérieur,
dans un lieu précis, si possible un lieu agréable, ça marche mieux.
Et, pour commencer, pas un lieu trop complexe.
Un lieu simple, ça peut être un champ dans lequel il y a quelques arbres, ou alors une plage sur une île déserte, ...
Vous allez vite vous rendre compte que même dans les lieux qu'on trouve simples, il y a quand même beaucoup, beaucoup de choses à visualiser.
Ou alors, si vous avez déjà commencé ce travail-là, voir cette vidéo, vous pouvez vous imaginer dans votre palais mental.
A l'intérieur, mais vraiment à l'intérieur de votre palais mental.
Pour commencer, vous allez imaginer tout les détails qui vous entourent, mais en utilisant réellement tous vos sens.
Visualisez mentalement le bruit des oiseaux, par exemple.
Oui, on peut visualiser du bruit.
Ressentez le vent, essayez d'avoir les odeurs, obtenez une image complète de cette réalité, avec tous vos sens.
Et ensuite, vous allez commencer à interagir avec cette réalité. C'est tout à fait possible!
Vous n'allez pas y arriver en deux jours, c'est sûr, mais le jour où vous allez y arriver, ça ne s'oubliera pas,
et vous serez capable de le faire pour toute votre vie.
Le point le plus important, l'astuce la plus importante, c'est le réalisme et le détail.
Il faut que vous visualisiez un maximum de détails et que ce soit le plus réaliste possible.
J'insiste vraiment dessus parce qu'on confond parfois la visualisation avec le fantasme.
Par exemple, je peux me visualiser dehors, en train de courir et de faire un marathon.
Je vais sûrement anticiper quelques petites choses, quelques possibilités, mais je vais me voir faire le marathon, point.
Là, on est dans le fantasme.
Par contre, si je fais une vraie procédure de visualisation, avec tous les détails,
avec la sensation des chaussures, avec la sueur qui coule sur moi, avec la fatigue, avec l'effort qu'on ressent dans une montée aussi petite soit elle,
avec tout le réalisme que ça comporte, alors là, ça va être bénéfique. Je vais pouvoir interagir avec ça et anticiper complètement tout mon parcours.
Voilà les amis, je vous le dis, votre cerveau est capable de faire ça! Ca demande un petit peu d'entraînement,
il faut vraiment muscler ça, mais en découpant avec les 3 exercices que je vous ai donnés, assez rapidement, vous allez obtenir des résultats sur le 1er exercice,
et vous allez vite pouvoir passer à la suite.
C'est vraiment cool à faire!
J'espère donc vraiment que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
La semaine prochaine, pour fêter les 30000 abonnés sur la chaîne, je vais faire une petite FAQ.
Je voulais faire une FAQ snapchat et je suis en train de changer d'opérateur en ce moment chez moi.
J'ai des galères avec internet. J'ai peur de ne pas pouvoir la faire comme je veux.
Et comme la dernière fois, on est passés par facebook, ce coup-ci, on va faire une FAQ twitter.
Vous avez donc jusqu'à mercredi soir pour me poser votre question sur twitter avec le #MENTALISME30000.
Ben, au moins, c'est clair comme hashtag.
Je vais donner un thème pour cette FAQ, histoire qu'elle ne parte pas dans tous les sens.
Pour celle-ci, on va se concentrer sur les vidéos, les vidéos de mentalisme et les vidéos sur youtube.
Vous pouvez donc me poser n'importe quelle question sur ce sujet-là.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'oubliez pas, par contre, avant de partir de laisser un gentil et très agréable et visualisant...
Pouce en l'air!
Et également de vous abonner à la chaîne en cliquant ici ou ici, parce que le mental vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour,
depuis le 1er janvier et jusqu'au 31 décembre, donc rendez-vous demain à 11h, ciao!